- [Instructor] What we're
gonna do in this video
is discuss some of the foundational ideas
for the United States of America.
And we could start at the
most foundational of ideas
and that's the notion of natural rights.
John Locke, one of the
significant Enlightenment thinkers
describes rights like life, liberty
and you might expect me to
say pursuit of happiness,
which is what we see in
the Declaration of Independence,
but John Locke refers to
life, liberty and property.
But even though his version
is a little bit different
than what ends up in the
Declaration of Independence,
most historians believe
that Thomas Jefferson
was heavily influenced
by John Locke's idea
of natural rights when Jefferson wrote
the Declaration of Independence.
And the idea here is that these are rights
that people should be born with,
that should never be taken away from them.
And in the video on social contract,
we talk about the idea of why
someone would form a government.
They would form a government,
they would give some rights
to a government in order to
protect these basic rights,
things like life, liberty, property,
the pursuit of happiness.
And so you might have some other rights
that one would say in a state
of nature people might have,
the right to do physical harm on others,
the right to imprison others,
the right to tax others.
But in a social contract,
we decide, hey, instead of everyone
trying to figure out things on their own,
let's give these rights to a government
and in exchange, the
government should protect
all of these rights for the individuals.
And, once again,
this is review from the
social contract video.
This is a notion of a social contract.
Now the next question is, all right,
so if we are willing to engage
in the social contract with a government,
what type of a government should it be?
And throughout most of human history,
governments have been
things like monarchies,
where you have a single individual,
maybe a king or queen, an emperor
some type of a conqueror,
who is the sovereign,
who rules over the state.
But you could have, you
could instead of having one,
you could have a small group,
which would be an oligarchy,
or you could go to the other extreme,
where the people are sovereign.
And the word for that,
and this is a key idea
for the United States,
is popular, popular sovereignty,
the people are sovereign.
The government is
accountable to the people.
Sometimes this could be
referred to as democracy.
Now the Founding Fathers
of the United States
were a little bit
suspicious of pure democracy
or direct popular sovereignty.
They were afraid that if
you start having factions
and a majority faction
were to come to power,
if you have a straight
democracy, then they might use
that power to strip some
of the natural rights
of say their political enemies
or people that they just don't agree with.
And so you have this other
idea of limited government.
Limited government.
And some of the key things
that limit the government,
you could just say
generally the rule of law,
things like the Constitution, including
how the government is structured,
the checks and balances in it.
The Bill of Rights, clearly
is a check on government.
And you don't just have limited government
when you have a democracy,
you could have a limited
government even in a monarchy.
The United Kingdom is officially
a constitutional monarchy,
where you have a monarch who's sovereign,
has very limited powers
because of things like
the rule of law.
Now the last idea,
that we're gonna talk about in this video,
is the notion of a republic,
or the idea of republicanism.
Because the Founding
Fathers didn't actually like
calling the United States a democracy.
Instead, they favored
calling it a republic.
And the word republic
can mean different things
to different people today,
depending on what context you use.
To some folks, today, it
means any form of government
that's not a monarchy.
To other folks it means,
okay, you have a democracy,
you have popular sovereignty,
but you have limited government.
You still have rights
that protect minorities,
rights that make sure that
even if people are not
in the majority, they are protected.
To the Founding Fathers,
they had a version of
this notion of republic.
They did view a republic as something
that would prevent the
passions of an unfettered
pure democracy.
But they thought it came mainly by having
a representative democracy,
that if you had a smaller group
of elected representatives,
as opposed to everyone getting
involved in every issue,
that they could calm the
passions of the crowds,
so to speak.
They also thought it was
logistically more practical.
Sure, ancient Athens could
have something closer
to a pure democracy, but that
was just a small city state.
Well, here, even the 13
colonies were significantly
more vast, and obviously the United States
would become even more vast than that.
And to appreciate this notion of republic,
right over here is a
quote from James Madison
in The Federalist Papers, Number 10.
And just for some context on the what
The Federalist Papers even were,
as we mentioned,
shortly after the
Declaration of Independence,
the Founding Fathers start drafting the
Articles of Confederation.
They go into effect in 1781.
But this is really a loose
confederation of states
that each, individually,
think of themselves
as sovereign states.
And it's really a pact that they'll engage
in war together, diplomacy
together, free trade.
But you have Shays's Rebellion,
and it's very clear, and
we'll talk about this
in other videos, that the
Articles of Confederation
are not powerful enough.
And so you have a
constitutional convention
in mid 1787, in which James
Madison is a central figure.
Some people discuss him
as the Father of the US Constitution.
They draft what is today the Constitution,
but then they have to
sell it to the states
in order for it to be ratified.
Alexander Hamilton has the idea of,
"Hey, why don't we publish
a series of papers?'
And they eventually publish 85 papers,
which will collectively be
known as The Federalist Papers.
And Hamilton writes most of them,
but he also recruits James
Madison and John Jay.
And Federalist Papers, Number 10,
which is perhaps the most famous,
is James Madison's discussion
of how do you avoid
factions taking over the government
and doing things that are not
in the interest of the people.
And I encourage you to read
all of Federalist Papers, Number 10.
But I have a very small quote here.
And this is James Madisons' notion
of what a republic was,
and he thought the United
States should be republic.
"The two great points of difference
"between a democracy and a republic are:
"First, the delegation of
government in the latter,"
so he's talking about a republic,
"to a small number of
citizens elected by the rest."
So he's really talking about
representative democracy.
But he thought this was a key
component of being a republic.
"Secondly, the greater number of citizens
"and greater sphere of country
"over which the latter may be extended."
That only through a
representative government
could you actually
govern over 13 colonies,
or even beyond 13 colonies.
And that's why, today,
obviously you might've had
something closer to a pure democracy
in ancient Athens, which was a city state.
But, today, almost any democracy
is some form of representative democracy,
which James Madison would
consider to be a republic.
But if you wanted to classify
the United States today,
a fair term might be it
is a democratic republic.
You definitely have popular sovereignty,
the people are considered sovereign,
but they don't rule directly,
they rule through representatives,
which by Madison's definition
would make it a republic.
So now that you're armed with
some of these basic ideas,
I encourage you to engage even more
with some of the founding
documents for the United States.
And on top of the
Declaration of Independence
and the US Constitution,
I encourage you to read
as many of the Federalist
Papers as possible,
because it's really an
explanation of the ideas
behind the US Constitution.
And you should start with
Federalist Papers, Number 10.
As you'll see, James
Madison is quite insightful.
He predicts how factions might form,
how parties might form,
and not always do things
in the interest of its people.
But I'll leave you decide
whether he was right,
whether forming a republic helps
this notion of factionalism.
And look at the world that we are in today
and think about whether
James Madison would be happy,
or maybe he would be
a little bit uncertain
about how things turned out.